foreign this is a political crisis
spilling on to Parisian streets
as anger turned to violence
seriously look what they're doing this
man shouts
[Applause]
where the police force lacking patience
and accused of using unnecessary Force
a nationwide strike against Emmanuel
macron's plans to raise the retirement
age to 64 started off largely peacefully
put frustration over the president
pushing through reform without a vote
gave this March momentum and then chaos
I think the will of the people and it
shows no sign of abating
French citizens are questioning their
leaders Democratic legitimacy once is a
democracy
but just now
we feel it's not really a democracy they
compare us to the people that attacked
the capital in the USA and I think that
it's absolutely disgusting
more protests will coincide with King
Charles visit in a few days a lavish
Versailles dinner likely scaled back
but macron's argument for reforms
economic insisting it will be law this
year
and Fanning the Flames of an
increasingly violent and radical protest
movement Adele Robinson Sky News Paris